une poutre pour symboliser le coup
d'envoi d'un renouvellement urbain ce
vendredi 15 octobre à chanteloup les
vignes les élus locaux ont lancé la
construction de la cité champeau dans la
commune le site s'inscrit dans le projet
de site éducatif simone veil à 6 des
champeaux c'est la première partie de la
cité éducative de champclos qui est fait
partie d'un plan de renouvellement
urbain va s'étaler sur plusieurs années
jusqu'en 2025 2026 et ici c'est le lieu
où les enfants de la cité éducative
seront accueillis avec le tout le
dispositif la belle cité éducative c'est
à dire cette nouvelle façon d'être tous
responsables de l'éducation la livraison
de la cité champeau est programmée pour
la rentrée 2022 le site aura pour
vocation à terme d'accueillir le pôle
adolescents et un pôle administratif
englobant les directions jeunesse
objectif redonner un nouveau souffle à
la ville de 10000 habitants c'est de
donner plus en tout cas d'apporter des
choses non seulement quantitativement
mais qualitativement un plus sur ces
quartiers plus fragiles pour renforcer
le sentiment d'appartenance pour
développer la mixité sociale pour
désenclaver
pour éviter
finalement
ce qu'on rencontre encore dans certains
quartiers c'est une ségrégation
résidentielle
l'ensemble de la cité éducative simone
veil sera livrée à l'horizon 2025